alright thanks for having me here I'm
going to be talking about algorithms
we're all talking about algorithms for
big data I want to talk about algorithms
for really big data so big that there's
no time no time to actually view all the
data so there's no time to actually
compress it and make it smaller for
working on it okay so what can we
actually hope to do without viewing all
of the data let me just give a running
example there's a lot of things you can
do but this is just one to keep in mind
as we go through the various models and
definitions the small world phenomenon
let's say the world is the people in the
world our graph that people are
associated with nodes we put edges
between people that know each other and
we want to know does the world have the
six degree of separation property that
is is it the case that every pair of
people is connected by a path of length
at most six in this graph and supposedly
there's a hypothesis it says yes the
world is um has six degrees of
separation there a Broadway plays on
this subject and movies and so the
question is easy true and how would you
determine whether such a property exists
for the world's graph well this is one
of the basic problems when you're
dealing with vast data it's impossible
to accept access all of it the
accessible data is too enormous to be
viewed by a single individual and once
you access it let's say you go around
and ask somebody who do they know things
can change people meet each other people
die people are born you find some kind
of lost island with people you didn't
even know existed in the you know off of
Africa or something so what this tells
us is that the what we teach in
undergraduate algorithms the gold
standard is a linear time algorithm once
you get that a plus you're done may not
hold in in real life it may be actually
inadequate so the only problem is how
can you even hope to do better than
linear time if you can't view even a
small port even a small fraction of the
data what can you even hope to solve
well we're going to have to change our
goals we're not going to be able to
solve for all or exactly type statements
and this is something for example
statisticians have known for decades
we're not going to be able to tell you
exactly how many individuals on earth
are left-handed but what we could hope
and similarly we're not going to be able
to answer a question like such as are
all individuals connected by at most six
degrees of separation what we can hope
to do the type of compromise we're going
to look for is to approximate the number
of left-handed individuals on earth okay
so that's a known statistical thing that
people have looked at furred for more
than decades and in the case of the six
degrees of separation we're going to
look for whether there's a large group
of individuals that are connected by at
most six degrees of separation okay so
these are the types of questions we're
going to try to answer we're going to be
looking at approximate questions and
we're going to look at various types of
approximation that are specific to these
problems okay so one of the types of
approximation we're going to look at is
something we call property testing it
tries to determine whether an input
object that's very large has certain
crucial properties and examples might be
whether a large large graph has small
diameter as in six degrees of separation
if you have an extremely large point set
you might want to know whether it's
cluster abell you might have a large
string and you might ask if it's close
to a code word you might have a large
description of a function the input
output table of a function you might
want to know things about this function
is it linear is it low degree polynomial
you might have a long list of strings
and you might want to know are they
alphabetized and lots and lots more okay
so I wanted to finally I want to give a
sense of what these property testing
questions are and I like to I'd like to
describe them as sort of in baseball
terms because I know dick likes baseball
in in the ballpark versus out of the
ballpark tests okay so you sort of want
to know am I am I in the right kind of
range so we want to distinguish inputs
that have a specific property from those
inputs that are far from having the
property but those inputs that are sort
of on the edge right on the edge it's
not clear whether they're in the
ballpark or out of the ballpark those I
don't care it's okay to say they have
the property even though they don't
quite have it but they're quite close
it's also okay to say they don't have
the property because they don't exactly
have the property so somehow we're
relaxing decision problems by saying
inputs that are close to having the
property either answer is okay okay now
why would you want to do such a thing
because it's it is a relaxed decision
problem it's giving you a weaker answer
the reason you might want to do it is
you can do it much faster much faster
okay I and in many cases it might be the
natural question to ask for example if
you've got some noise that's you always
expect to be present for example you
have data you have many points in space
you don't really expect it to be cluster
abell into K clusters with radius D you
because you always expect some crazy
noise you know so you're not really
that's not really the question you want
to know is whether it's Katie cluster
ball you want to know whether 99% of it
is Katie cluster abell and similarly our
breath problem the diameter of the world
network we don't really care it I don't
think maybe you do I don't whether it
whether the world really has the six
degree of separation property we want to
know if you if the world approximately
has the six degrees of separation
property that is do most of us fit in a
graph that has six degrees of separation
I it makes sense also when the data is
constantly changing and you never expect
to be exactly on property or whatever um
and it also can be used in algorithm
design because it gives a fast sanity
check to rule out very bad input so if
you have to compare a lot of if you have
to do many types of processings and you
want to rule out the really bad ones so
that you don't spend a lot of processing
time on them then you can use such
algorithms and finally it's actually
I'll say more about this later but it's
related to the model selection problem
in machine learning okay so let me give
a couple of examples if given the input
output table of a function you can tell
if the function is a homomorphism in
constant time independent of the size of
the domain ok so the size of the so it's
the running time all you need is a
constant number of queries and the
running time depends not at all on the
size of the domain ok
another example is the social networking
example that I just mentioned you can
tell if a graph that has constant
average degree has the six degrees of
separation property in constant time
it's independent of the number of nodes
it does depend on the degree of the
graph okay so those are two examples in
constructing a property tester what do
we need to do we need to find some kind
of characterization of the property that
we're trying to test its efficiently
testable that you can have a hope of
running really quickly and that objects
that have the property satisfy this
characterization while objects that are
far from having the property are
unlikely to pass this characterization
and that's usually the bigger challenge
okay so for example the homomorphism
property of function it's defined by for
all XY f of X plus f of y equals f of X
plus y but you can't test this for every
x and y because you might have a very
large domain okay so so this is not
something that we think of as a good
characterization another bad
characterization is foremost X f of X
plus F of 1 equals f of X plus 1 now
that is true that if that were true for
all X that would characterize
homomorphisms it's nice because testing
for most X you can you can do that with
sampling so you don't really need to
check every single X the problem is and
one other nice thing is that good
functions pass that test so that's great
the only problem is many bad functions
also pass that test so that's not a good
characterization either for testing
homomorphisms but here's a good
characterization foremost XY f of X plus
f of y equals f of X plus y you can
check that this holds by random sampling
and what you can prove well it's easy to
see the functions that are homomorphisms
have to pass that test and what you can
prove is with functions that are far
from homomorphisms are likely to fail
that test for the proper choice of most
and i am it addresses since then but
this is known for abelian non abelian
groups z22 the end at all there's
special cases and there's so there's
been a lot of work done on this and I
left out all references but another
example six degrees of separation here's
to bad testing characterizations for
every node all other nodes are within
distance six because that's not
efficiently testable you can't go
looking at every node and foremost notes
all other nodes are within distance six
again not efficiently testable but
here's a good characterization due to
parnis and Ron that for most notes there
are many other nodes within distance six
and it turns out that that's good enough
for testing for distinguishing graphs
that have six degrees of separation from
graphs that are far from having six
degrees of separation okay many more
properties our study on grass functions
point set strings and there's amazing
characterizations that are known for
problems testable in the graph and
function testing models so for functions
people have studied linearity low total
degree polynomials trigonometric and
elliptic functions of FI invariant
functions cuantas these are functions
that depend on few of the input
variables okay I operation tables to
tell if it's a group or a field testing
what their function is monotone convex a
modular and low complexity is it can you
describe this function as a small um
decision tree can you can you describe
the function as a small dnf and lots and
lots more okay for grass a lot of really
interesting results are known here I'm
just going to you know quickly summarize
in a slide but I should say that I'm not
doing it justice there's really a lot of
beautiful deep results in this area for
dense graph properties it's completely
characterized what's what's testable in
constant time so we know exactly which
properties can be tested in constant
time it's really beautiful results based
on extensions of the summer ready
regularity lemma and I'm not going to
talk about it more but I do urge you to
find out about this for Hyper finite
breaths is sort of the other end of the
spectrum these are pretty sparse graphs
these are graphs where you can cut out
epsilon fraction
the of the edges and remain with really
small components here it's also
completely characterized okay what's
testable in these cases what about
general sparse graphs not hyper finite
but not dense so there's a lot no the
characterizations are less precise here
and in fact here it's actually more
interesting to look at what can be done
in sub linear time but not necessarily
constant time for example bipartite miss
you can distinguish bipartite graphs
from graphs that are far from bipartite
it in the complexity required is rudin
time connectivity diameter i mentioned
color ability rapid mixing and being
triangle three these are examples of
properties that have been studied many
beautiful tools have been used I
mentioned some ready regularity lemma
random walk techniques local search
simulating the greedy algorithm which
I'll discuss in a moment and all kinds
of tools are borrowing from parallel
algorithms as well so there's a lot of
beautiful results those are only some of
the references and I just want to say
before I go on that a lot of other
combinatorial properties have been
considered sets properties of strings
such as edit distance and
compressibility properties of metric
spaces cluster ability convex hull embed
ability properties of code words and
properties of words being longing to low
complexity classes such as given a fixed
context-free language is the word close
to an element in that context free
language okay so I wanted to say um
before I finish talking about property
testing I wanted to say something about
a new model that was recently suggested
by Vulcan bleh and this would be Alvin
blow and liu yang we're trying to bring
the property testing model closer to a
model that makes sense in the machine
learning settings so we've in all of
these results I mentioned we assume that
you have query access to any part of the
input that you'd like to see in the
machine learning people don't like that
because they say will you only get
random samples so here is a model that
is attempting to sort of bridge the
difference between
the two areas where you can only query
labels of points from a given sample and
they look at they have some beautiful
initial results in this area and it is
useful for the model selection problem
okay so that's sort of a brief outline
of what's going on in property testing
but now I want to turn to classical
approximation so we have some you know
we have some value that we're trying to
approximate and we'd like to give an
output it's close to the value of the
optimal solution but we're not going to
have enough time to actually construct
the solution so some examples of places
where we have sub linear time
approximation algorithms are for minimum
spanning tree vertex cover max cut
positive linear programming edit
distance and various other problems I'm
going to just give it a little example
of vertex cover so just because I think
we come from a lot of backgrounds I'm
going to make sure we're on the same
page a vertex cover is a subset of the
notes that touches every edge okay so
what's the minimum size of a vertex
cover well we know this is a classic NP
complete problem but we also have a
polynomial time multiplicative to
approximation algorithm for it and it's
based on the relationship between vertex
cover and maximal matching ok what's the
maximum matching this is a matching it's
a subset of the edges well so first of
matching is a subset of the edges in
which no vertex is touched more than
once it's like possible marriages and
nobody's allowed to get married twice
and we have a maximum matching if you
can't add any other edge in E without
violating the matching property now
what's nice about a maximum matching is
that even though it's not maximum but if
you have any maximum matching and you
take all the nodes that got matched in
that maximum matching that gives you a
pretty good vertex cover ok it's no more
than twice the value of an optimal
vertex cover and what's nice about
maximum matching is they're very easy to
compute ok so we're going to get a
really good vertex cover and we're going
to use the fact we're actually going to
use the fact
you can get a good vertex cover from a
good maximal matching from any maximum
matching I any maximum matching gives us
a good vertex cover and maximal
matchings are in some sense easy we'll
see why okay so what we're going to get
right now is a constant time
approximation for vertex cover on sparse
graphs so I'm assuming that the degree
is bounded by a constant we're going to
output a y which is at most twice the
optimal vertex cover that's what we lose
this multiplicative factor of two we
lose because we're going to use a
maximum matching to get it and then
we're going to have a little bit more
error and epsilon an additive error that
we have because we're sampling and so we
have to have somewhere error okay all
right how are we going to do this well
we're going to use an Oracle reduction
framework where we're going to construct
some Oracle and this Oracle is going to
fix in its head a specific maximal
matching okay and then we are going to
ask questions from this Oracle and it's
going to tell us whether any given
knowed you wasn't was matched in this
mattress maximum matching okay so I'm
going to ask questions of the Oracle the
Oracles going to tell me yes you you was
matched or no you was not matched okay I
remember you used to call it the birdie
dick so the birdie okay so now we're
going to use this Oracle and just
standard sampling to estimate the size
of the cover i'm just going to pick a
random node ask the Oracle is this in
the matching or not and it's going to
tell me the answer and then I'm just
going to sample and estimate what
fraction of the graph is in the maximum
matching that's all we're going to do
okay the only problem is how do we
implement this Oracle okay so there's
two approaches actually I the first
approach was suggested by partisan run
was to notice that there are these there
have been a lot of recent advances in
distributed algorithms where they have
constant round up algorithms for solving
various problems there's really a lot of
beautiful work going on in that can
and you can sequentially simulate the
computations of one of these constant
round algorithms and figure out what a
specific node would have done okay and
you can use that to simulate your Oracle
okay and it only takes constant time
because because it's constant round and
you have a degree bounded graph the
number of nodes that you could possibly
depend on is it most D to the number of
rounds if d is a constant and the number
of rounds is a constant that's just a
constant okay so that's one idea that's
used it's a very beautiful idea and it
leads to really nice algorithms but i'm
going to talk now about another approach
which is to figure out what the greedy
maximal matching algorithm would do on
you and this is why it's nice to depend
on maximal matching because that's an
algorithm which the greedy out that's a
problem for which the greedy algorithm
actually works okay so always to do is
figure out what the greedy algorithm
would have done unload you okay what's
the greedy algorithm there's some
ordering on the edges any arbitrary
ordering but you have to pick one okay
and the greedy algorithm just goes
through the edges in order and for every
edge UV checks if you and B have been
previously matched if neither one was
previously matched to add this new edge
UV to the matching okay so it's pretty
easy to see that this is maximal because
if there's some edge that was not placed
into this matching it's because either
your V was previously matched okay so
there's no way that there at the end of
this you can have an edge remaining with
neither you or V not matched okay what's
nice about this though is this algorithm
works under any ordering it doesn't
matter okay so now to decide if an edge
is in the matching you have to know if
the adjacent edges that come before E in
the ordering were placed in the matching
or not you don't actually care about the
edges that come after E in the ordering
okay so if I want to know if this it ok
so here these numbers tell us the
ordering of these edges ok so now I get
a query I want to know is 112 in the
maximal matching or not so I have to
figure out the adjacent edges well this
one 113 comes after it in the ordering
so I don't care right but 111 comes
before it in the ordering so I have to
figure out what happened to 111 okay
well to figure out what happened to 111
I have to figure out what happened to
110 to figure out what happened to 110 I
have to figure out what happened to 89
and so on half it the problem that i can
have here is we have in if we have an
arbitrary edge order we can have very
long dependency genes to figure out what
the greedy algorithm would have done ok
so what no win and onak noticed in is
that if you assign a random ordering to
the edges then the random order has
short dependency chains in expectation
okay so this is a really nice result and
of course greedy works under any
ordering in particular it will work
under the random ordering okay so they
were able to show that based on this you
can get a constant time approximation
algorithm the dependence in this in
their original analysis was terrible in
terms of D but they gave a heuristic in
there L in their paper it said always
recurse on the least ranked edge first
and later worked by yoshida yamamoto and
ito showed that this actually leads to a
running time its polynomial in the
degree and finally with additional ideas
you can get query complexity that's
nearly linear in the average degree for
general graphs so if you have a constant
degree graph then it's a constant time
approximation scheme for vertex cover if
you have a dense graph then you get a
linear in n approximation scheme for
vertex cover but notice that the input
size was like N squared so its root the
size of the input ok so that's vertex
cover there are more complicated
algorithms for lots of other problems
maximum matching set cover positive LP
there's some work also in the dense case
it gives such a nice sum algorithm and
one of the questions that's open is if
in all these cases the dependents can be
made polynomial in the degree sometimes
they sometimes we know how to do it
sometimes we don't
it's a very interesting open question
okay I should mention that there's even
better results for these kinds of
approximation problems for hyper finite
graphs that includes for example planar
graphs and there's a lot of beautiful
results but there really are a lot of
nice open questions in this area I want
to mention at this point another model
we've been talking about the case where
you have large inputs what if you also
have large outputs but you don't
actually need to see the whole output
you just want to see one piece of the
output do you really need to see the
whole input okay so this is something
that may be familiar to many of you for
example locally list locally decodable
codes have this same concept where the
input we're thinking of as the encoding
of a large message the output of the
decoding algorithm is actually the
original large message and if you want
to know what's the ice bit of the
original message you would like an
algorithm that makes a few queries to
the encoding and tells you what's the
ice bit and in fact you can design codes
so that few queries are needed in order
to give this answer okay another similar
type of algorithm our local
decompression algorithms many people
have studied these here the input we're
thinking of is the compression of large
data and the output of the decompression
algorithm is the out is the original
large data and again you want to know
what's the ice bit by looking at very
few places in the in the original
compressed data and what you'd like to
hear do here is design compression
schemes that compress well and we're
very few queries are needed to answer so
for example if you use standard Lempel
Ziv then it compresses it compresses
well but to decompress and figure out
what's the ice it may take you a long
time but you can make a modification of
Lempel Ziv that I'm you know give me a
parameter epsilon you make modification
we're in a sort of online setting never
compresses to more than 1 plus epsilon
what Lempel Ziv would have done but you
can recover the I fit in poly
logarithmic time
okay so that's an example of a type of
result you would get here I and more
generally we've proposed a model of
local computation algorithms where you
have an input X it's actually written
down there's an output Y that's implied
it's kind of in the air and now you have
this local computation algorithm and you
query this local computation algorithm
and ask it ok what's the ice bit of the
output what's the J's bit of the output
and this what will call the LCA will
make a few queries to the input and give
you answers to your queries about the
different bits of the output ok so I the
hope is that you could have a bunch of
these lca's running in parallel but not
talking to each other so these are not
it's these are not parallel algorithms
these are sub linear time algorithms
that do not talk to each other um but
they can in parallel answer about the
same why so one of the difficulties here
is you need to maintain consistency when
there's more than one legal solution ok
so what more can you do in this model
I've already mentioned a few types of
results it turns out that there are many
optimization problems that you can solve
such as maximal independent set I mean
what you the difficulty here is I want
to say whether or not I'm in the maximal
independent set and be consistent with
what a different LCA would say about you
know my neighbor node or somebody two or
three hops away so I want to make sure
that everybody answers according to the
same maximal independent set scheduling
problems hyper graph coloring even SAT
problems how to how to assign truth
values to the inputs the techniques are
similar to the Oracle reduction
framework but the Oracle requirements
here are more stringent the reason is is
that in those previous results i
mentioned to you the Oracles had to run
in constant in constant or poly
logarithmic expected time ok what we
need is what we need our worst-case
bounce so expected time it's not good
enough for us so what we do is compute a
partial solution which decides the
answers for most notes and here you can
reviews various techniques you can
either simulate local distributed
algorithms or you can simulate
the greedy and what you have to prove
then is not only it works for most notes
but the remaining nodes where you don't
know the answer yet they are in small
connected components okay so I and there
to show that what remains is only in
small connected components you can use
an analysis that's similar to the becker
alone type analyses which is used to
give algorithms for to find solutions
guaranteed by lovis local lemma type
theorems and you can also analyze via
Gulf and Watson what's nice about saying
that you have only small connected
components if they're really quite small
there Polly logarithmic in size then you
can just do brute force ok so what it
gives you is poly logarithmic time local
computation algorithms for solving these
problems ok so i should mention there's
also other works and local algorithms
for ranking webpages graph partitioning
and these these are similar in spirit
often the running times are given in
terms of some expansion type parameter
of the graph but um but these are an
another group of results which are very
similar in spirit our property
preserving data reconstruction you sort
of you're getting some data that's
supposed to have a certain property and
you'd like to essentially clean it so
you'd like to give query access to the
cleaned up data as opposed to the
original data ok how much time going on
ok all right so I'm going to spend the
rest of this talk on a totally different
model now we not only do we not have
time we don't have samples to the input
ok so I think we don't need to compute
convince anybody in this room the
distributions are important and they
occur everywhere but let me focus on a
specific type of distribution let's
again I want a running example let's
talk about the lottery ok so let's say
you want to know is the lottery fair or
unfair I you know some websites clean
the lotteries not so fair that past
number histories can be the key to
predicting future winners and in fact
it's a true story so this is a story
pointed out to me by my former students
of onek the Polish letter e multi
low-tech if you choose uniformly at
random
a distinct 20 numbers and this is
actually implemented by balls in a
machine and it turned out that the
initial machine they used was biased the
probability of 50 to 59 was too small
and thanks to Erik price for giving me
this graph I nobody's here but he
definitely part of the big data program
and you can see that these guys here are
too small and people made a lot of money
once they figured that out okay so when
we were studying this we were in New
Jersey so we looked at the New Jersey
pick three and pick 4 lottery here the
pick 3 lottery you pick three digits in
orders so there's a thousand
possibilities you know 0 to 9 0 to 9 and
0 to 9 you have 10 x 10 x 10 pick for
you pick four digits in order so you
have ten thousand possibilities let's
assume that the lottery draws our eye ID
and when we did these tests the pic 3
data this was you can see October
fifteen two thousand the pic three had
run 8520 two times there were a thousand
possible outcomes so we ran this through
the chi-square test and it gave us
forty-two percent confidence that it was
uniform okay we did the same thing for
pics for but big forest started later
and it only had six thousand five
hundred and forty-four results and
remember that here there's 10,000
possible outcomes so when we ran it
through chi-squared it gave us no
confidence in the outcome being uniform
okay so what can you do how would you
know that the lottery is uniform if in
general what we're interested in this
part of the talk is distributions on
very large domains given samples of a
distribution you might want to know all
kinds of things like the entropy the
number of elements maybe the shape if
you want to know is the distribution
monotone maybe it's bimodal you might
want to know if it's close to uniform
gaussians if ian but you don't get any
assumptions on the shape of the
distribution so you can't assume that it
was smooth that it was monotone or even
that it was like a normal distribution
ok so these kinds of questions are
considered all over statistics
information theory machine learning
databases algorithms physics biology and
the key question is how many samples do
you need in
terms of the domain size so in
particular do you actually need to
estimate the probabilities of each item
in the domain in order to answer these
types of questions or can the sample
complexity be sublinear in the size of
the domain ok if we get sublinear in the
size of the domain that's going to rule
out standard statistical techniques
which allow you to learn the
distribution so you can't just like use
Chernoff bounds or plug-in estimates or
chi squared or whatever that you like to
use ok so that's our goal here is
algorithms with sublinear sample
complexity so let's start with one
question that we've already mentioned
similarities of distribution ok so we're
going to ask our p two distributions p
and q are they close or far and p we're
going to assume it's given via samples
and q could be either known for example
we might be asking is p the uniform
distribution or we could be asking is p
the Gaussian distribution with these
specific parameters or we could be
asking is it 15 so we might have a or
any other arbitrary distribution that we
might have in mind may be written down I
don't care so we're not going to worry
about time for right now we're just
going to worry about sample complexity
okay the other situation you could think
of is Q might also be given via samples
you might get two sets of samples and
asked rvs the same distribution or are
they very different okay so let's start
with a question of whether P is
uniformly that helps us with the
lotteries and it turns out that
distinguishing whether P is uniform from
the case where P is far in l1 norm from
uniform takes data of root n where n is
the domain size samples okay so i think
it i was told i'm supposed to assume you
all went to boot camp but that's the l1
norm right there but i didn't go to boot
camp so I ok all right so now the way
I'm just going to say a bit about how
the algorithm works it's based on
estimating the l2 distance from uniform
the l2 distances on given right there
but notice that if you take the l2
distance of a distribution from uniform
and you
sort of write it out you'll notice that
once you do these algebraic
manipulations the summation of pi is
just one and summation of 1 over N
squared your something that end times so
that whole term ends up being one over N
so you get this really nice very simple
identity that the l2 norm squared of P
from the uniform distribution is equal
to the collision probability of P minus
1 and N and let's assume you know n okay
so that means if you can estimate the
collision probability and you know n
then you can get a good estimate on the
l2 distance squared from uniform of P ok
so that's how we're going to do it we're
just going to estimate the collision
probability to estimate the l2 distance
from uniform and then the way the upper
bounds work is estimate this collision
probability and then use the known
relationships between the l2 distance
and the l1 distance to to get a good
estimate of the distance from uniform
now one issue here is that the collision
probability of uniform is one over N so
the question is do you need something
like linear and many samples to estimate
the collision probability and the answer
is no because if you take linear and if
you take theta of square root n samples
you have theta of n many pairs of
samples so and you can use those pairs
to get something like linear and many
estimates of the collision probability
so then what you need to do is show that
even though these as to these samples
are not these samples of collision
probabilities are not independent
they're independent enough to give you a
good estimate of the collision
probability so this is some kind of
chebyshev argument and i should also
mention that Peninsula uses a totally
different estimator I and so um okay so
that gives us root and sample complexity
and it's easy to see that you need root
n samples to distinguish uniform from
far from uniform the reason is this if I
take a random subset of the domain
exactly half the size of the domain okay
but a random subset and then they take
uniform distribution on that all right
that's very far from uniform
distribution on the whole domain in
other one distance that's really almost
it's not quite as far as you can get but
it's quite far so you want to say that
that's very different from uniform
distribution but the problem is if
because we pick things randomly any
algorithm that tries to distinguish this
from uniform can't use the names of the
elements that it sees because it doesn't
know how they were picked so all it can
use is collision statistics and the
first time it's going to see a collision
is after rude and samples or some
constant times root and many samples
okay so Rudin is required for this
problem and in fact you can get you can
in fact Peninsula showed you can get a
lower bound of rude n over epsilon
squared ok so let's go back to the
lottery it turns out we do have plenty
of samples for determining whether it's
uniform if we use these new methods ok
so i want to say since i don't have much
time i won't say how but it's actually
nearly the same complexity to test
whether p is any known distribution so
you give me any distribution write down
all the probabilities for me and i can
also test that in root n samples and
it's just by reduction to the uniformity
testing problem ok so I'm not going to
say much about that but now let's talk
about the problem of testing closeness
of two distributions where both are
given via samples ok so I so now both P
and Q are given via samples I know
nothing about either them what do you
think is the how many samples do you
think I'm going to need here do you
think I how many people think I can do
this in route on samples how many people
don't think you guys are very quiet ok
so all right well the answer is theta of
n to the two-thirds and we found this
quite surprising in fact we thought
there was a mistake in our calculations
for one bini for a long time we were
trying to fix this he turned out there
was a lower bound ok and in fact this so
we were shocked uh and the question is
why is it so different when you know cue
from when you don't
q and it turns out that you can show the
this is something we've understood for a
long time collision statistics are all
that really matter but the collisions
statistics on the heavy elements can
hide what's going on in the light
elements so all you need to do is
construct pairs of distributions where
the heavy elements are identical and the
light elements are very different and
because the collisions of the heavy
elements are really hiding what's going
on in light elements and because also
you don't know which elements are heavy
or light like the testing algorithm has
no idea what's a heavy element what's a
light all it's these are collisions it
really doesn't understand what's going
on and that's basically what the lower
bound is based on I want to say that
much of the kind of the top level
outline for this was understood way back
in the beginning but actually there were
problems in the proofs making what
everybody thought to be obvious making
it precise and it took them Paul valiant
in 2008 was able to give us the missing
technical tools that allowed us to
finally get this some result I mean that
allowed Paul to get this result but
thanks to his tools we've used them in a
number of other related lower bounds and
it's been quite good for the field okay
i want to mention another thing what
happens if you want to additively
estimate the distance because all these
previous results you were supposed to
answer pass if p is equal to Q and you
were supposed to say fail if P is far
from Q in the middle I don't care so
what if you want to actually estimate
the distance what if you want to pass if
P and Q are close and fail if pink you
are far you know and you say i know p
and q aren't identical i just want to
pass if they're close well that's a
harder question and that needs fada and
over log in samples and that was shown
by Greg and Paul valiant and this is
really a cool result and it's quite
surprising in a number of areas ok so
the ideas behind these algorithms are
collisions tell you everything you can
use collisions to determine sort of
wrong behavior too many collisions we've
seen implies that you're far from
uniform but the Greg and Paul valiant
showed that you can use linear
programming to determine if
there is a distribution that has the
right collision probabilities and also
the right property for lower bounds for
symmetric properties you can show that
collision statistics are the only
relevant information but you do need new
analytic tools because they're not
independent and so the valiance gave us
a central limit theorem for generalized
multinomial distributions okay so I how
much okay in two minutes I will say for
some other questions of interests are
entropy and support sighs I might take
three intervene support sighs um this is
a question okay so we started working on
this when I was at NEC this guy was a
William bialik was on Maya it was also
at NEC at the time one of the physicists
and it turned out that we were both
working on the same problem the only
reason we found out is because he was on
my evaluation committee but but it was a
great example of two people in almost
next door offices working on the same
thing and not even realizing it for at
least a year and they were really
interested in entropy over very large
domains because they were using it to
determine whether neural signals were
understanding how they were
understanding data okay so for them
really large domains were very important
because it gave them more accuracy in
looking at these signals okay another
place where you'd be interested in
entropy is estimating the
compressibility of data and what I'm
going to I'm going to just give a quick
summary for multiplicative
approximations in general you can't get
in a nice multiplicative approximation
of entropy but kind of for stupid
reasons and that's because it's really
hard to distinguish very close to zero
entropy distributions okay and just like
its distinguishing a zero entropy
distribution from an almost zero entropy
distribution it can take a lot of
samples because you need to see the
second element and you might never see
it for a while but for but if you're
told that the entropy is at least some
constant then you can get good
multiplicative approximations of the
entropy so
if you want to get a gamma for gamma
greater than one multiplicative
approximation of the entropy then you
can do that with n to the 1 over gamma
squared samples so for example if you
want a 2 multiplicative approximation of
the entropy you can do it in n to the
one-fourth many samples okay and that's
tight better bounds are known in certain
cases and a very similar thing happens
for estimating support sighs okay but
for additive for additive approximations
it's the same story as we had before
it's theta and / logon okay and that's a
really cool result many properties have
been studied independence flat
distributions Poisson binomial
distributions monotonicity of
distributions properties of multiple
distributions and lots more many open
questions and many approaches for trying
to get past the lower bounds assuming
you have more information than just
samples other distance measures and some
sorts of competitive models and there's
lots and lots of open questions here but
what I want to conclude is for many
problems we need a lot less time in
samples than one might think and there's
a lot of really cool ideas and
techniques that have been developed in
these areas and a lot of great
colleagues to work with
there is a good question we can take it
otherwise the project afraid so we're
going to break them til 1030